Film Courage: How are you softening some of
the screenwriters you’re working with who
are either too defensive or too much of a
namby-pamby “yes” person?
Lee Jessup: It is a balancing act.
I think once writers start getting notes and
a lot of notes, they learn…they learn.
Because you’re going to get notes that are
outright offensive to you.
But you learn to take the good with the bad.
I always tell writers as they prepare for
the industry, go find people who will hate
your work, those are the people whose notes
you want.
You don't want the people who will tell you
how brilliant you are, how perfect it is.
You’re not going to learn anything from
that.
You’re going to learn how to take notes
from getting notes that are really offensive
and finding something in there that you can
use.
What is the core of that?
What is the little kernel inside that note
that you can take and do something with and
really move the material forward with?
And listen, I remember this from my days from
getting notes as a writer and getting infuriated
and coming back and going “Okay, there was
something there.
What was that thing that was there?
What is the note giver really saying?”
So you want really to teach writers to take
notes, to be receptive to finding that kernel,
that truth, that is in every note or in most
notes.
You also want to work with writers the way
that I work with writers and that is in not
giving them the answers when they are like
“Okay, here is this note so I am going to
execute it that way…Is that good?”
No!
Figure out your way to execute that note and
I get writers coming back and going “There
was one note that said this, how do I implement
it?”
You figure it out.
You’re on your own.
I’ll sit with you and I’ll brainstorm
with you once you have the direction but it
has to be your direction.
And that is where you have to listen to your
inner writer.
You have to really foster your talent, your
sensibilities.
Of course it has to be malleable.
You have to be able to work with other people’s
sensibilities, but the key to being a great
writer is taking other people’s ideas and
making them your own.
And falling just as in love with them and
being just as invested in them as you would
be had your idea or concept originated with
you because the reality today is that 2014,
1,800 WGA members made income in the film
industry.
Roughly 132 scripts sold.
What does that mean?
That means that over 1,600 people made their
money writing pages, doing writing assignments.
So how do you become that writer who does
writing assignments and does it successfully?
You’re able to take a kernel of an idea
and make it your own and fall in love with
it.
And really take it and run with it in a way
that makes other people want to work with
you.
Question for the Viewers: Do you give your
script to people who will tear it apart?